hi everyone my name is david and i'm
here to introduce you to grammar on khan
academy
welcome i'm so glad you could join me
so let's start by asking the question
what is grammar
what is this thing why is it worthwhile
to study it why would you want to put up
with listening to me well first of all
grammar is a set of conventions and
rules
that govern language so what's the
difference between a convention
and a rule well a rule is kind of the
bare minimum
of what it takes to make your language
understandable by other people
right so in order to make a car work for
example in order to make it move forward
as
intended the wheels have to go on the
bottom instead of on the roof
that's a rule the idea that all cars
should be painted teal
for example is a convention now is that
true that all cars should be teal no not
necessarily but that leads me to my
second point
that grammar is context dependent the
kind of grammar that you use throughout
your day
changes it depends on who you're talking
to what you're trying to say and how
you're trying to say it
and so we use multiple kinds of grammar
throughout our days and throughout our
lives
another thing you need to know is that
you already know so much grammar
just from living and existing in the
world and talking to other people
you know how to put a sentence together
you if you can understand me
then you know so much about grammar you
know more than i can teach you
what these videos are for is to give
names to the things you already know to
give you a greater command of them
and i want to say too that this these
videos are only about a very specific
kind of grammar it's called standard
american english
but i want you to know that there are
many englishes
and you know what they are all great
they are all
wonderful and vibrant and important and
special
and what i do not want for you to take
away from these videos
is that i'm trying to teach you what is
right and what is wrong
if the kind of english you speak doesn't
sound like the kind of english i speak
that is okay
you know you are great what i want to do
is give you the tools to harness
language
to harness english and use it
any way you want i mean i'm saying i
don't care what color your car is it
could be pink
it could be green it could be purple it
could be paisley
you know i'm just trying to make sure
your wheels are on straight
you are a grammarian you have made a
study of grammar throughout your entire
speaking and reading life
and i firmly believe that you can learn
anything
welcome to grammar on khan academy david
out